cosa tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono famiglie ed oggi siamo
tornati su happy da quando avevo fatto
la lei ragazzi non ho più fatto episodi
di happy to di questo è il centounesimo
come agar i campi li facciamo un
episodio dedicato ai cani non sto
scherzando
purtroppo più score facciamo questo come
primo livello di oggi perché so che
questi mi piacciono che tra l'altro è
riuscito a fare un sacco di poltrone
live e vincerli tutti quindi alla fine
avete visto anche ma che cazzo da fare
sta roba è a punteggio ma butt a piantar
kula velocior voglia di fare punteggio e
famosi clever ford comunque ragazzi
avete visto veramente nella live che
sono riuscito a fare robe senza i tagli
quindi sapete che sono forte
dati che sono vivono ma dai è nelle
palle cos'è sta roba che non ho mai
giocato
ok giù tutto dritto
sarà un fenomeno degli altri
queste tecniche da ninja che ho
sviluppato per schivare le mannaie
esposto che cazzo è successo sono cagato
addosso cosa è successo
c'è ma nel nome ha colpito mai ma come
ma non è vero
qualcosa e che lasciato livello mentre
stavo arrivando al traguardo ma
[ __ ] dai ragazzi li facciamo la
perché non ho capito c'è veramente non
si è capito niente
mi sono legatissimo piano no stai calmo
zio è calmissimo devi stare jolo sono
vivo ce la posso fare se riesco a tutti
ma tanto che cambia se me ne sparaventi
o se ne spara una detto gli spara a
tutti nella stessa direzione non cambia
assolutamente niente
allora ti ammazzo la madre questo dei
capi per la vittoria già fatta già fatta
ce l'ho fatto io ho fatto vai vai vai
vai veloce prima che l'aci veloce
velocissimo tutto nell'anno zio tutto
nell'anno ci ho messo sei vite per fare
sta roba ma ne è valsa la pena ragazze
mario kart
non ho fatto mario kart su questo questo
sarebbe mario kart io lo chiamerei più
nonno ciack art sì però ecco vede ha
capito subito che si gioca io devi
andare avanti alla bravo vedi kakà è
tanto il sogno così ci si ammazza quindi
non ti preoccupare mi chiamo me va
veloce
bellissimo non puoi lanciare anche gli
oggetti giochi sì 6 no
dopo una roba a era una demo ecco perché
migliaia la durata tanto è per carità di
dio
l'ater boltro anzi questo sempre di sly
per il criterio come mica se dice poi
cos'è l'ici year to play vai giochiamo
dove lancia non ci credo
bellissimo e poi ci sono io che lancia
una palla e v ciao zio ma non ho vinto
scherzavo è cascato luke a caso non so
perché eccolo niente ho sempre l'ultimo
sono troppo forte ragazze si mette a
giocare a sly teriaca d'ospedale c'è
scritto prova a prendere nextlevel per
passare allo slider phone mi dice un
altro livello fighissimo
spero che cerchi loro azzecco subito
[Musica]
ragazzi devo beccare sluyter fall per
forza perché sono ecco fa chi è
scusatemi se la gama e vero legami con
casinò cioè prima devo schivare ma
perché per quale motivo devo schivare di
vermi bello però bellissimi che al
meglio di slater io
mica un altro parà più facile arrivare
primi sluyter io che fa starò la prova
mover jump guarire vabbè ci ho provato
ragazzi specie ci prova
ma vaffan che fa quello cha va bè
ragazzi devo riuscire a finire sta roba
che ormai una questione di vita o di
morte
per lui è quanto incassato
[Musica]
ce la posso fare ragazzi vita più
difficile di quello che sembra mica
quanto sono andati in alto stavolta
allora sei stronzo da eva iniziare a
minchia incredibile grazie
ci mancava l'accompagnamento finale
grazie mille la smetto sport delle
differenze di potato sono 234 mi piace
troppo autonomia
devo trovare le differenze ora io li
adoravo sti giochi non lo so perché ha
prima differenza e questa è la seconda
questa cosa che ci stanno fatto nemmeno
la luce quanto ci sono non lo so aveva
avevamo a caso il tubo
[Musica]
eccolo e lavandino nella mia ci ha messo
un'ora e mezza per non era questo ma
[ __ ] cosa c'è di strano sia una
mattonella più sottile dell'altra
scommetto che una stronzata lega la
porta a che c all'ombra ma vai a [ __ ]
che sei perché ha disegnato una pagina
non ho ancora finito c'è ancora c'è
qualcosa ma serio dai basta che palle o
sono scemo sono tutto orbo io quegli
occhiali vedo meno di prima ragazzi mica
è incredibile zoom l'aspetto b hai
sbagliato a scrivere il suo zio ski e
zombie ok nostri scrive zombie favore
vuoi perché non stravolgere gli zombie
bello ti piace questo livello al nostro
che ti di intelligente rispetto a tutti
gli altri
ora quando ci hanno anche i conetti in
testa ma mai ci manca solo quello guarda
belli meraviglioso
non ho mai visto a livello così bello
anche in macchina ce l'hanno loro la
patente non ce l'ho io perché i ragazzi
sono una notte
resterà geniale ragazza questa era
fottutamente geniale io sono bello ma
guarda che si cura di intelligente che
ci vai vai a veloce forza se io vedo
arrivare al traguardo non puoi perdermi
così non puoi è la madonna nicchia volo
della della vita ragazzi ce la posso
fare lo sento scassato un tavolo scusate
pressando niente sono morto e rimasto
fermo così raga mi dispiace
e stata una bella corsa premier sono
stato ucciso da uno stereo succede
foreste sono partiti c'è qualcuno che
vuole a prescindere urla perché si
chiama shadow fare solo perché ha sempre
desiderato vedere un cespuglio che ride
e quello cespuglio è che non si capisce
ancora tu
ciao il mio nome del ciad e il sì ma
magari fa mi legge pagherai per i tuoi
sbagli a stronzo de merda parte che è
riuscito giusto
ok adesso ha ucciso anche ma non ho
capito perché la devo pagare perché non
ho capito cosa ho fatto
ok ok fantasy sopravvissuti simo vai vai
a vedere raga non ho capito dove sto
andando di procedere
mi sono gratis i moai 0 vai zio perfetto
perfetto dovevo salire qua sopra non
l'avevo capito scusate dove stiamo
andava perché si chiama shadow fa ciao
nonno el'inter bra sanfrè informiamoci
che formi a ok non tanto si vede che sei
tu minuti che fa il misterioso chi sarà
mai quell'uomo non poco idea della
caverna aveva chiesto di trovare una
chiave gialla in una caverna che non ho
capito dove non è quello di gaber ma
[ __ ] ma di che caverna sta
parlando a tutti sta andando avanti che
so io e vabbè palo gay hwa jung e juande
se la voglia di battermi prima ma
[ __ ] deciso quasi in obiettivi
colpisce sei stupido non si muove
michele bot ragazzi il boss della vita
non ho mai visto un boss così difficile
presa la chiave dove chiude shadow
martin heidegger archivi il sound finley
6 gb un vezzo ray mi dai la vittoria
frate come me la dai la vittoria come
devo cliccarlo
è stato perso un braccio così a caso va
bene è stato un livello pieno di
significato grazie ai ragazzi facciamo
un paio di miei livelli che dall ultimo
episodio che ho fatto ne sono arrivati
un botto e tipo questo la vj impossible
scusi che ci ha scritto andati sotto no
come con che fisica c'è qualcosa qui
sotto che non vedo spiega ma è un muro
invisibile non puoi scendere neanche
volendo mai frate vai frate senti
facciamo così però cisti si è impegnato
va bene così plodio sto livello non ha
senso prigi versus per fare gen passi
facendo per questo che mi sembra più
fatti dalla cei versus parkour
ciao fa vi sono io nella live hai fatto
il primo oggi il secondo spero ti
piaccia
ok grazie per avermi fatto saltare
timpani così a cazzo di cane zio ciao fa
vi sono sempre io quello di fa vj verso
una scritta illegale in tutti gli stati
perché per quale motivo spiega non è
scritto niente di strano però potrei
incazzarmi quello potrebbe essere
illegale in tutti gli stati mai bye bye
bye bye bye bye ho capito che livello è
che ci ho messo una vita senza tagli
quindi adesso che i tagli ce la farò
subito
ci ho messo poco buttati che morbido
quasi si toccano ma non avevo dubbi
guarda ai ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo
perché ancora non ce la fa vi questo
livello pensato per metterti alla prova
supera questo quiz di cartoni animati
giapponesi per passare alla prova finale
nella serie guardate online come si
chiama e portava unità è la madonna che
anche che cazzo di domanda a sketch un
cazzotto chieri gaia sicura gasquet show
mcauley pokémon però si chiamava
veramente così si chiamava chirito ha il
nome avere aggiornato scemo nel nome
vero che lo scemo io come si chiama il
capo balestra che accompagna nella serie
poche ma è mai minchiata serie pokemon
bianco e nero spighetto fa vigente
grazie avermi messo una risposta falsa
così a prova di minchione perché non ci
ha mai azzeccato non l'ho visto bianco e
nero e il cartone dragò finalmente lago
ball z quante sono le sfere del drago il
drago delle sette sfere giallo non può
però nessuno sa quale terza prova lo
sguardo è troppo mai scritto trovo
questo sì che è illegale cazzo aveva
mica devo fare un centro incredibile è
lo sapevo io mica ce l'ho fatta se per
sbaglio tributi di sotto vinci lo stesso
non mi sono buttato li ha uccisi
li ha uccisi fammi scendere e belga
tutto pagato suo gioco ok ma non a lui
ha capito che io sono forte e quindi mi
ha fatto vincere perfetto ecco allora
casuali spero che ha visto iniziare
scelto concludo che l'episodio primo
video dietro di sé dopo i 100 fatto
anche con gli occhiali ed ha un non so
che di intelligenza ma manco bouquets
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi big
light super il centounesimo episodio e
cosa che siamo invece l'argomento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook è
meglio tornare descrizione sono serviti
schemi ci vediamo il prossimo video
belle ragazze